hijo mío sabes que mamá te quiere
los que te han hecho daño
serán castigados
estoy segura que eres más feliz en el
paraíso
en diciembre David paseaba por la calle
con un amigo cuando fue atacado por una
banda de jóvenes lo golpearon y lo
dejaron morir David solo tenía 15 años
sus asesinos no han sido capturados
cuando mi marido y yo llegamos al
hospital mi hijo estaba grave
tenía un Piñón de motocicleta incrustado
en la cabeza
tenía el cráneo aplastado
la cara hinchada y ensangrentada
estaba irreconocible
estaba destrozado David es víctima de la
violencia juvenil que envenena en la
sociedad Indonesia hay bandas callejeras
por todo el país
se graban a sí mismo participando en
carreras de motos palizas y ataques con
machete y luego comparten las imágenes
en internet Cuanto más violento sea el
ataque mayor será el revuelo sus
víctimas Son miembros de bandas rivales
o a veces transeúntes inocentes Aunque
la policía está tomando medidas el
número de incidentes relacionados con
bandas aumenta cada año me asusta tengo
miedo de salir
no nos sentimos seguros por culpa de las
bandas de
clity significa tradicionalmente vagar
fuera para matar el tiempo pero ahora
tiene un significado mucho más oscuro
simplemente matar actualmente se utiliza
para referirse a las bandas juveniles y
yo yakarta es el epicentro de esta ola
de delincuencia Es difícil decir con
exactitud Hasta qué punto se ha
extendido es probablemente que las
estadísticas oficiales subestimen el
verdadero alcance del problema ya que
muchas víctimas no se ponen en contacto
con la policía incluida las que acaban
en el hospital logramos convencer a un
miembro de una banda para que nos
permitiera filmarle se desplaza con los
60 miembros de su banda y normalmente en
moto Este es su escondite
aquí es donde guardo mis armas
uso este sable para acuchillar las
chaquetas de mis enemigos
aquí hay un equipo de bicicleta
cuando
lo ven se asustan
tanini
puso esto para romper sus cascos y
hacerles daño
un día cuando atacábamos a nuestros
enemigos intentaron huir la
pero corrimos tras ellos y los
apuñalamos uno de ellos perdió tres
dedos
[Música]
picada sigue en la escuela al igual que
ocho de cada diez jóvenes miembros de la
Banda según la policía
antes buscaba un sentido a mi vida
al unirme a Una Pandilla me sentí más
fuerte
[Música]
y ahora me respetan en la escuela sobre
todo los más jóvenes
si dejo la banda antes de salir del
colegio los demás miembros se borrarán
de mí y tendré que pelearme con ellos
mis padres no saben nada de esto si lo
supieran me echa
comienza en la escuela en la década de
1990 las rivalidades de tipo mafioso
empezaron a arraigarse entre los
estudiantes de secundaria las bandas
prosperaban reclutando nuevos
estudiantes David el joven asesinado en
diciembre de 2022 asistía a esta escuela
los profesores han empezado a organizar
actividades extraescolares para disuadir
a los alumnos de vagar por las calles
pero la iniciativa no pudo salvar a
David la directora dice que se siente
impotente para detener la violencia y
quiere que los padres asuman más
responsabilidad
cuando yo era joven los jóvenes iban en
bicicleta pero hoy en día tienen moto
antiguamente las peleas estallaban entre
dos personas y se resolvían dentro del
grupo
pero ahora implican armas
los padres deben comprender que los
tiempos han cambiado
las autoridades intentan tomar medidas
represivas expulsan a los estudiantes y
organizan patrullas nocturnas contra
clity algunos esperan que el deporte
pueda propiciar el cambio en este club
de artes marciales los antiguos miembros
del clity han cambiado sus armas por
guantes de boxeo
algunos de mis alumnos solían llevar un
estilo de vida terrible
Se levantaban por la tarde Y se quedaban
fuera toda la noche
pero se sintieron bien cuando empezaron
a ganar en el deporte y se sintieron
capaces de hablar de sus problemas
empezaron a vivir mejor se entrenan aquí
dos o tres veces por semana
el deporte ya está teniendo un efecto
positivo uno de los protegidos del
entrenador antiguo miembro de clity se
ha convertido en campeón nacional de
kickboxing pero Dado que los delitos
eclities se han duplicado en los últimos
cinco años la suya es una rara historia
de éxito